one of the most popular questions that I
ever receive is does the Bitcoin having
actually matter will it impact price
when the having occurs next in order to
understand the Bitcoin having we have to
go back in time there was 50 Bitcoin
every 10 minutes that came into
circulation for four years after Bitcoin
launched after that four-year period or
so the 50 Bitcoin dropped to 25 cut in
half hence the name the Havoc now
bitcoin's daily incoming Supply the
number of Bitcoin that come into the
supply every 24 hours has been cut in
half multiple times we went from 50
Bitcoin every 10 minutes to 25 from 25
to 12 and a half twelve and a half to
six point two five now of course that's
where we are today which is about 900
Bitcoin a day but every single time that
the Bitcoin having has occurred
bitcoin's price has appreciated rapidly
within 18 months you can think of the
Bitcoin having as a supply shock we go
from 50 Bitcoin come coming into the
daily Supply to all of a sudden it goes
down to 25. if there's less Bitcoin
coming into the circulating Supply and
the demand stays the same then obviously
price will go up you don't need to go to
very many economics courses other than
the 101 class to understand how supply
and demand economics would have this
type of impact on price now there's an
entire cohort of the population that
believes that the Bitcoin having does
not matter their thought process is
aligned with the efficient market
hypothesis now the efficient market
hypothesis has won major rewards and it
is believed to be true by a lot of
people I personally happen to disagree
with it though the efficient market
hypothesis is the idea that everyone who
has the same information in the market
will come to the same conclusion
obviously that is not true in my opinion
that would mean that no matter how much
more work you do you can't gain an
advantage in the market instead I
actually think the exact opposite of the
efficient market hypothesis is true
there are plenty of people who know that
the Bitcoin having exists but there's
plenty of people who don't there's also
plenty of people that know that it
exists but they can't tell you when it's
going to happen and on top of that there
may be many people in the market that
not only know that the Bitcoin having
exists when it is going to occur but
they don't know what the impact will be
and so you can give the same amount of
information to two different Market
participants and they will come to two
different conclusions that disproves the
efficient market hypothesis and
therefore that means that the Bitcoin
having will have some sort of impact now
we can argue and debate how severe the
impact will be but obviously if you are
going to cut the daily incoming supply
of an asset in half by 50 it is going to
have an impact on price as we have seen
time and again in history whenever the
Bitcoin having has occurred there has
been a rapid appreciation in price
within the first 18 months I do not
believe that is going to change in the
next Bitcoin having instead I actually
think that more and more people will be
aware of the Bitcoin having they'll know
when it's coming and they likely will
get long Bitcoin and wait for that price
appreciation to occur the reason why
that could actually have an explosive
impact on bitcoin's Price is because the
more people that are buying Bitcoin and
holding it waiting for this event the
more illiquid the asset is and if all of
a sudden the Bitcoin having is coming
the media is talking about it people on
Twitter are tweeting about it and
everyone is waiting in anticipation then
more and more folks will speculate on
the having to occur therefore they will
go and they would try to buy Bitcoin but
if there is an increase in demand at the
same time that you have an illiquid
market and a supply shock we will get a
repeat of what we saw in 2020 leading
into the having in 2020 I continued to
write tweet and record videos all about
what I thought was going to occur I was
shocked that we were going to get the
Bitcoin having at the exact same moment
that the Federal Reserve and the U.S
government was going to conduct massive
quantity of easy so look whenever we get
to uh recessive periods or kind of
slowing growth central banks have two
tools right they can cut interest rates
which they just did yesterday and they
could print money quantitative easing
and so when they do both of those things
it usually takes anywhere between 6 to
18 months to actually feel the effect of
those tools and what it's going to do is
going to coincide with the Bitcoin
having which we can get into what that
is and so we think that cutting rates
printing more money uh and then this
systematic structure of Bitcoin is going
to lead to a higher prices for Bitcoin
over a long period of time now we have a
major event happening
argue the greatest event for the
cryptocurrency uh The Happening
happening in May can you shed some light
on what you expect to happen to price
here in May
yeah so I've been writing about this now
for uh for almost a year really since
last like May or June uh saying look
we're headed into an environment where
uh the Fed was gonna have to cut
interest rates to near zero or zero uh
they've obviously done that uh we've
been saying that they're gonna have to
uh generate lots of quantitative easing
they're obviously doing that on a
historic level and those two things were
to coincide uh at the same time or near
the same time as the Bitcoin having
which is the incoming daily Supply gets
cut in half from 1800 Bitcoin a day to
900. now if you go back to 2008 2009
remember gold Drew Down 30 in 2008
during the liquidity crisis but coming
out of that when quantitative easing was
announced Etc from 2009 to 2011 we saw a
massive increase in price about 3x and
gold eventually hit an all-time high now
imagine in 2009 2010 and into 11 50 of
the gold miners basically shut off their
operations so 50 of the incoming daily
Supply just disappeared it would take a
scarce asset make it scarce so right at
a time when all these investors are
running to it and the value of gold
would have gone higher that's
essentially what I think is about to
happen here everyone's going to look for
inflation hedge assets whether it's
Bitcoin or gold as they do that you're
going to get the Bitcoin having 50 of
the daily incoming Supply gets uh taken
away and so you're taking a scarce asset
making it scarce right at the moment
that everyone wants it in their
portfolio and therefore I think that it
provides this Rocket Fuel um kind of for
the future outlook of Bitcoin that meant
that there would be more dollars chasing
fewer assets and therefore price was
likely to appreciate rapidly just as we
had seen many times before and that's
exactly what we got Bitcoin went from
around eight thousand dollars to almost
seventy thousand dollars about a 700
percent price appreciation in that
18-month window and so yes Bitcoin has
drawn down significantly since then but
we will have another having about 2024
and when that 2024 Bitcoin having occurs
I don't see any reason to believe that
it won't have a positive impact on price
now I don't have a crystal ball I can't
tell the future there's risk with all
types of investing as we know history
does not necessarily repeat every single
time
but we can use it as a guide for what
the probability of the future is and so
if we see a supply shock coupled with a
rapid price appreciation there is a good
reason to believe that a future Supply
shock would lead to some sort of price
appreciation now the severity of that
move is where I may not agree with the
most hardcore Bitcoin maximalist I don't
necessarily think that a future having
is going to lead to thousands of percent
of price appreciation I actually think
that each future having will have less
and less of an impact but it still will
have an impact and so as we head into
the Bitcoin having make sure you
understand what the having is how it
technically works when it is going to
occur and how historically that is
impacted adoption price and other facets
of the Bitcoin Network in this next
Bitcoin having I expect a repeat of many
of the future things but as always if I
get new information that would change my
mind I fully reserve my right to change
my mind that is a sign of intelligence I
just have not yet found any information
that would make me think the next time
is any different than what we've seen
time and again in history
hope this helps you understand the
Bitcoin having and what potentially
could happen let me know in the comments
do you agree or do you disagree and what
do you think will happen